good morning believe nation today's
message is think big over to you sheryl
sandberg i think the most important
thing about growing a business
successfully is thinking ahead about
where you're gonna be so I think about
like the three tips you have for scaling
an organization the first I think the
most important is to think big people
think about how do you manage how do you
motivate an organization and I think
about management you know basically the
science of administering a business or
leadership and my favorite definition of
leadership is the art of accomplishing
more than the science of management says
is possible when you have a big vision
when you're thinking really big
something that can change the world so
my favorite example connecting the world
which was Mark Zuckerberg was vision for
Facebook that's the kind of thing that
excites people and motivates them that
gets them to follow you not just because
they work for you and they need to do it
you say well because they believe in
what you're trying to do and when you're
trying to really scale an organization
you need to go really quickly and get
people to accomplish more than they
thought was possible and I think that
comes from internal motivation which
really comes from a vision that's big
enough she'll said something really
important that I want to repeat
leadership is the art of accomplishing
more than the science of management says
is possible I love that and my take on
it is as an entrepreneur you need to
dream big you need to think big about
something and that involves thinking
beyond the current realm of possibility
that's thinking beyond what currently
exists that's living in almost a
different future world where inventions
haven't been made yet in order to make
your dream happen and you need to go and
make those things happen if you want
people to be motivated to come work for
you you want people to invest in you you
want people to write about you in the
media you want to wake up yourself and
be motivated to go and do some work
you have to have the courage and the
audacity to think big beyond what
reasonably expected beyond what logic
says is possible nobody wakes up in the
morning and says I want to go live a
mediocre day today nobody everybody
wants to be a part of something bigger
but most people don't have the courage
and the audacity to go out and actually
do something bigger that's on you that's
what an entrepreneur does believe so my
question for you today is what is your
big dream that is beyond the realm of
current possibilities I want you to
stretch your mind today and leave it in
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso